after a ton of speculation and
disappointment surrounding V live CS2
has just received its first massive
bandwave with hundreds of accounts
facing the hammer along with the
thousands of dollars they had in skins
but even with this good news some are
speculating on whether or not this is
the start of something good or just
another Band-Aid on the bullet wound
that is the cheating
epidemic Okay so over the last few
months I've been chronicling the current
war against cheaters in counter- strike
and where we last left off things were
looking pretty rough this a smoke going
a
do counterterrorist win this is op
as now if dudes brazenly live streaming
themselves cheating wasn't bad enough
things only got worse with the full
release of Counter-Strike 2 with
unfettered access the floodgates opened
and blatant cheaters could be found in
basic every corner of the
game if they know I'm know
I'm B
down I got pre-fired I think this guy is
cheating the same
guy
[Laughter]
downend oh my God they're not
even oh my my
God where'd he
go
wait okay Thor CS pointed out in a
Twitter post that even the new premier
ranking system had been infiltrated
there were some dudes on there with like
100% win rates because they were
purposely being boosted by cheaters
point is was bad cheaters live
streaming cheaters in high and low ELO
cheaters in Premier nowhere was safe and
with pros and content creators now
feeling the Wrath as well it led to
these larger voices publicly calling out
valve for what felt like a complete lack
of an antiche it was thought that back
live at the very least could detect
blatant cheaters but since that
obviously wasn't the case it got some
wondering if it was even on now amongst
those who thought that vac wasn't even
turned on were those hoping it was a
deliberate Choice by Valve that they
were holding off collecting data until
CS2 launched I thought that this was
wishful thinking and as I said Counter
Strike 2 came out and it only got worse
but when whether it was the onslaught of
bad Optics valve was facing or they were
truly collecting data something finally
happened earlier this week on October
2nd it was revealed that hundreds of
accounts were caught in cs2s first
massive ban wave now for those unaware
people do get banned in singular
instances but valve is known for
conducting these massive band waves
usually because a certain cheating
software becomes detectable by vac and
in this situation it seems that's
exactly what happened if you remember
there was a very popular cheating
software I spoke about in my last video
video called aimware and according to
those who are tracking these bands
players who use that service were most
of the ones caught in this recent back
wave the exact number of unique cheaters
band is a little hard to tell right now
but to put it in perspective one dude in
particular lost 580 Plus accounts
because he had them all tied to the same
phone number but that's just the tip of
the iceberg because as we know when you
get back banned you also get trade
banned meaning the Skins you had on your
account become effectively worthless
most of these people aren't that stupid
so the accounts that have like two dors
are probably using inventory Changers
but in some cases cheaters were losing
hundreds or even thousands in skins now
in the aftermath pros plebs and content
creators alike were relishing in the
demise of these cheaters hell even one
aimware admin was making fun of those
struck however this is where we get to
some of the more pessimistic reactions
amongst the community although even one
cheater getting the hammer is good news
many believe that it just wasn't enough
some went so far as to say that hitting
aimware was low hanging fruit and I do
get the hesitation for a round Round of
Applause despite some suggestions that V
live has some sort of AI learning
component to it we straight up don't
know how it works or the power of it
even if aware doesn't come back
something that's currently undetectable
will probably just take its place which
would be a massive problem if we
overhyped back now if we wanted to be
hopeful this could be the start of
something good as we know CS2 is
currently receiving multiple updates
every week and will be for the
foreseeable future maybe vac is evolving
alongside it for me personally I haven't
faced anyone where I could definitively
say that they were in fact cheating but
on the other hand my brother who never
plays CS was in an office comp map with
teammates who were blatantly cheating
and even telling everyone they were I'm
curious to hear from you guys are you
finding yourself stuck in these God
awful lobbies or have your match has
been mostly clean like mine on top of
that are you optimistic about the future
of vac or do you think that cheating
will just always be a part of
Counter-Strike no matter what valve does
you know and it makes sense that like
okay okay cool like all these cheaters
are getting banned like some of them are
saying hey everyone I reported I
received a notification that they were
banned in this most recent wave but
they're like that doesn't kind of like
help the fact that I lost the ELO